democrats in the media continuing to
melt down of the supreme court's
abortion ruling that led states decide
how to handle the issue of abortion
members of the squad leading the way in
pushing radical ideas and how to respond
let's listen together the supreme court
has engaged in the overreaching of its
authority
in denying the human and civil rights of
any pregnant person biden
should entertain expansion of the
supreme court he should forcefully come
out in ending the filibuster
pregnant person you could also
substitute women if you're looking to
expedite the sentence
and the media is losing touch with
reality too claiming this is the end of
democracy while trashing middle america
it just sucks man it it really does i
mean you know it's like the the country
it's no longer a democracy right i mean
we're
it's no longer majority rule
no certainly not the senate certainly
the representation from the supreme
court the problem is that middle stuff
it's those states in the middle that
that that red stuff
why they get to tell us what to do when
the majority of us live
out you know new york california and
we're paying for all this crap really
wow all right it's the middle stuff the
red stuff uh for more on that uh let's
go to jessie uh jesse did she make it a
lot of sense the middle stuff puts the
food on the table that she's paying for
at dinner they probably put the gas in
the car that she's driving to dinner
there will be no fox news without the
middles
i mean everything this country works
because of the middle stuff
um i want to talk about what the squad
said that there there's going to be a
woman strike yeah you're worried about
that i'm a little worried about that
right of course you i'm watching wheel
of fortune
who's going to turn over the letters
great point
over and turn over is letters do you
know how much vanna white makes she
probably makes six times as much as i
made and it does right no i think about
the repercussions here brian
our ep at the five is a woman
she's not going to show up to work we're
left to our own devices we're going to
go from first to fifth like that
the fbi agents that are women how are
they going to infiltrate jane's revenge
we're going to have male
guys put put wigs on and makeup and have
to go is this going to happen at home
too
who's going to mess with the thermostat
who's going to tell me that my clothes
clash before i leave are they not going
to do everything brian i think we're
underestimating how serious this is
they have us right where they want us
you're not understanding it's like
cryptic
for more stereotypes let's go to dana
by the way this was done in 1975 90 of
women in iceland participated shutting
down the country
and no one noticed greenland iceland
maybe i don't know um i think that the
the middle stuff is super offensive and
it's
it's exactly the same type of thing of
what hillary clinton said in terms of
deplorables it's the same language and
they just they they do believe it then
they always have to have these really
thoughtful discussions about why did we
lose another election and this is why
the other reason that you have the
middle stuff is so that you can win
world war ii yeah
great point uh judge the middle stuff if
you look at this issue we don't have a
democracy in that majority rule you have
the senate you have the you have the
white house you have the house yeah
majority rule and the supreme court that
she didn't even know how government
works these people have no idea what's
going on and that's why i had my my head
in my hands aoc says if the the supreme
court engaged in an overreach of its
authority does she have any idea what
the supreme court's job is in terms of
the constitution does the last woman she
says we're no longer majority rule by
the way the supreme court doesn't make
decisions based upon majority rule the
way they want to pack the court they'll
make it another legislative branch and
what makes them think they're the
majority by the way what makes them
believe
why do they why do they get to tell us
how to live in new york and california
uh harold i think you got you have a
unique point of view because you're in
uh you're from tennessee you've got
republicans democrats living together
you're doing the impossible
like so why why did what do you think
about this mindset that she just so i
live in new york now but tennessee is
home you know i don't agree with that
characterization i i think that
i understand what some of her i believe
i understand where some of the
frustration and angst is coming from
when you think about
we could very well go back to 50 years
ago as it relates to choice and freedoms
that women have enjoyed i i don't i
think as a country we're always looking
for i don't remember time when that when
the court actually took rights away
from people the way that this case has
been done i agree with you judge that i
think the congresswoman from queens has
it wrong in saying that they they don't
have this authority they do have this
authority and the question is what can
you do politically to try to redress it
i do think what we all have to step back
and ponder is
the world we want to live in when it
comes to these the kind of expectation
of privacy for people uh particularly as
it relates to a
choice for women in their bodies and
whether or not abortions is it 15 to 20
weeks is this something the country
wants and we should all speak up about
that and pass through the law and and
and we should and our courts should
understand that i said on this show two
days ago the contraceptive
gay rights
um uh other expectations of privacy that
people have that i think justice thomas
contemplating his decision i think that
is a real and honest and serious and for
that amount of robust discussion we need
to have as a country about whether we
want that or not and i i know as one
vote i don't i want 15 to 20 weeks and i
think we ought to have an expectation of
privacy conversation how do you feel
about connecticut new york uh uh and
california saying hey come to us for an
abortion as well that's what i was gonna
say i mean wanda does she not realize
that this happens nothing changes in
california new york except that those
taxpayers in those states are now going
to be a part of the abortion tourism
trade that is going to take place unless
you want to put a pub tent in
yellowstone park this way on federal
land that's another one of their ideas
in order to have an abortion in a state
that doesn't allow it if they do on a
federal end they're going to think about
doing that interesting times hi everyone
i'm brian kilmeade i want you to do me a
favor i want you to click to subscribe
to the fox news youtube page this is the
only way that i know for sure that
you're not going to miss any great
commentary any great news bites any
great interviews coming your way on fox
you can get it all here on youtube so
subscribe right now